Je m'appelle Nanfu.
En chinois, « nan » signifie « homme »
et « fu », « pilier ».
Ma famille espérait un garçon,
qui deviendrait le pilier de la famille.
Et quand ils virent que j'étais une fille,
ils me nommèrent Nanfu quand même.
(Rires)
Je suis née en 1985,
six ans avant que la Chine n'annonce sa politique de l'enfant unique.
Juste après ma naissance,
les autorités locales ont ordonné à ma mère d'être stérilisée.
Mon grand-père s'y est opposé
car il souhaitait un petit-fils pour perpétuer notre nom.
Finalement, mes parents furent autorisés à avoir un second enfant,
mais ils durent attendre cinq ans
et payer une amende conséquente.
Durant notre enfance, mon frère et moi
étions entourés d'enfants uniques.
Je me rappelle ressentir une certaine honte
à avoir un petit frère.
Je pensais que notre famille avait mal agi en ayant deux enfants.
A l'époque, je ne me demandais pas
d'où venait ce sentiment de honte et de culpabilité.
Il y a un an et demi, j'ai eu mon premier enfant.
C'est la meilleure chose qui est arrivée dans ma vie.
Devenir mère
m'a donné une perspective totalement nouvelle sur ma propre enfance,
et a fait remonter les souvenirs de ma jeunesse en Chine.
Depuis trente ans,
toute ma famille a dû demander au gouvernement la permission
d'avoir un enfant.
Et je me suis demandé
à quoi ressemblait la vie sous la politique d'enfant unique.
J'ai donc décidé de tourner un documentaire sur le sujet.
Une des personnes que j'ai interrogées
est la sage-femme qui a vu naître tous les bébés de mon village,
moi y compris.
Elle avait 84 ans quand je l'ai interviewée.
Je lui ai demandé :
« Savez-vous combien de bébés vous avez vu naître ? »
Elle n'avait pas le nombre d'accouchements.
Elle m'a dit avoir réalisé
60 000 avortements et stérilisations forcés.
Parfois, a-t-elle dit,
un fœtus de plusieurs mois survivait à l'avortement,
et elle devait le tuer après l'avoir fait naître.
Elle se rappelait à quel point ses mains tremblaient
quand elle faisait cela.
Son histoire m'a choquée.
En me préparant pour le film,
je m'attendais à ce que ce soit la simple histoire de bourreaux et de victimes.
Les gens qui définissaient la politique
et ceux qui en supportaient les conséquences.
Mais ce n'est pas ce que j'ai vu.
Alors que je finissais l'interview de la sage-femme,
j'ai remarqué un coin de sa maison
qui était décoré de drapeaux faits à la main.
Chaque drapeau avait la photo d'un bébé collée dessus.
C'était les drapeaux envoyés par les familles
qu'elle avait aidées à résoudre leurs problèmes de stérilité.
Elle m'a expliqué qu'elle en avait eu assez
de pratiquer des avortements et des stérilisations -
son seul métier était désormais d'aider les familles à avoir des enfants.
Elle disait être emplie de culpabilité
d'avoir œuvré à la politique de l'enfant unique,
et elle espérait qu'en aidant les familles à avoir des enfants,
elle contre-balancerait ce qu'elle avait fait dans le passé.
Et il m'est apparu clairement
qu'elle aussi avait été une victime de cette politique.
Tout le monde lui disait
que ce qu'elle faisait était juste et nécessaire à la survie de la Chine.
Et elle a fait ce qu'elle pensait juste pour son pays -
je sais à quel point ce message était fort.
Il était partout dans ma jeunesse.
Il était imprimé sur les boites d'allumettes,
sur les cartes à jouer,
les livres d'écoles, les affiches.
La propagande pour la politique de l'enfant unique était omniprésente.
[Quiconque refusant de stériliser sera arrêté.]
Voici les menaces pour ceux qui auraient voulu désobéir.
Le message était tellement enfoncé dans nos esprits
que j'avais grandi en étant honteuse
d'avoir un petit frère.
En chaque personne que j'ai filmée,
j'ai pu voir combien leur cœur et leur esprit
avaient été influencés par la propagande,
et combien leur volonté de se sacrifier pour une grande cause
avait été pervertie en quelque chose de sombre et de tragique.
La Chine n'est pas le seul pays où cela arrive.
Il n'y a pas de pays sans propagande.
Dans les sociétés censées être plus ouvertes et plus libres que la Chine,
il peut être encore plus difficile de déceler la propagande.
Elle est cachée dans les informations,
les publicités, les campagnes électorales
et les réseaux sociaux.
Tout cela afin de changer nos esprits sans qu'on s'en rende compte.
Toute société est vulnérable et risque d'accepter la propagande comme une vérité,
et aucune société où la propagande remplace la vérité
ne saurait être véritablement libre.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)